so this is directed by Mel Gibson which
is funny because in the ads that I saw
initially for this was like from the
director of Braveheart whoever that may
be
I just diapers like we're like that is
straight up Mel Gibson apparently they
can't say his name in Hollywood still
but Mel Gibson has directed a new movie
for us we're going to find out if the
world has been missing him for the past
few years or if the hey no big loss
we'll see
[Music]
Hacksaw Ridge so hacksaw rage is a story
of a man named Desmond dass did you know
who that was I didn't until this movie
probably shoots pretty incredible story
world war 2 s escalating people are
joining up is that a patriotism and
pride they want to do what's best they
want to fight for what they believe in
the 105 for freedom murder Desmond das
played by Andrew Garfield joins the army
in hopes of being a field medic one
thing now he doesn't kill people he will
not kill people he will not even handle
a gun which seems like quite a conundrum
really it's fine because Mel Gibson
movies are known for being in your face
violent in very relevant ways if the
movie does take place in wartime Jim
Caviezel is getting his ass kicked for
an hour and a half point is Mel Gibson's
good at directing violence and this is a
war movie where someone doesn't kill
anybody either gonna be the greatest
pairing ever or it's gonna be a big
mistake we're never gonna hear from Mel
Gibson again but talking about what I
liked in hacksaw Ridge first of all
everybody in the movie did a fine job
Andrew Garfield was great he's the
optimist is one of those people were
it's he's so good at being optimistic
you just see his infectious smile you
want this dude to succeed because you
could tell he's just such a sweet guy he
obviously has seen enough in his life to
be like no I saw some stuff in my youth
I don't need guns or violence I don't
like any of it I don't want to do it I
want to help save lives in a time in a
war where lives are straight-up being
taken Hugo Weaving plays his dad we're
used to seeing Hugo Weaving as Agent
Smith Elrond the voice of V for Vendetta
it's not all these played this life when
I think Hugo Weaving
that's what I think of it was great to
see him play it's just alcoholic abusive
dick I just like it when actors like hey
here's a side of me you're not used to
yeah boom there you go I'm doing well on
that speaking of doing well in that I
have to give all the props to Vince
Vaughn one of my main gripe sigh always
have about Vince Vaughn any time I see
him in a movie is the fact that he
always plays the same character Vince
Vaughn and wedding crashers is the same
Vince Vaughn and dodge ball who was the
same Vince Vaughn and everything we're
talking everything
he's always Vince Vaughn in fact I'm
never really sure he knows he's being
filmed this one he placed a drill
sergeant this dude is hard he does not
understand why this guy just won't pick
up a weapon he gives him [ __ ] and inside
a war you almost understand where he's
coming from is like can you rely on this
pacifist to save your ass out there on
the bat
Phil point is I love that Vince Vaughn
took on this role I love the fact that
he was cast in this movie it reminded me
of David Schwimmer and Band of Brothers
where you're like your rods holy [ __ ]
you're not always Ross that was good job
actors should do more of this don't
always play the same thing good call on
doing it Vince Vaughn you did well but
really this movie is two movies in one
the first half of this movie it's great
seeing Andrew Garfield stand by his
beliefs the really strict believes for
sure to an insane degree we're at a
point I'd be like yeah I would just pick
up the rifle show them I could use it
and be on my way but even he wouldn't do
that but it's great to see our character
our wonderfully loveable hero just stand
by what he believes in when the entire
world is going against him or at least
his entire platoon then the second half
is when we get the hacksaw read you're
like oh yeah there's a Mel Gibson movie
holy God it's going down it was great
because the way it happens it hits you
like a truck which is effective because
up until now in this movie you've heard
about war they've heard about war but
you haven't seen it yet in this movie
and then it hits you you're like oh yeah
that's right this is a Mel Gibson war
movie it was shocking it's supposed to
be shocking it was effectively shocking
and I loved how well Andrew Garfield's
character this guy was a very religious
person and that religion was the main
reason he did not pick up a gun and kill
anybody in this time of war you don't
need to be a religious person to
appreciate the movie it addresses it as
a strong perspective for him but you
don't need to be religious to appreciate
the spirit of the film you see hacksaw
Ridge is a movie about optimism and the
human spirit conquering also the most
powerful thing you can have unless faces
2016 by 2016 I mean the most venomous
shittiest divisive year I have seen yet
just as a human being is social media
waste it's gross everywhere and in that
this movie coming out this year it's
great to see someone who is just a nice
guy who wants to save lives just doesn't
want to take other lives if I had a
gripe about hacksaw Ridge I would say at
a point in the movies like all right we
got to do this thing and then they do
the thing and it's straight up just kind
of you feel like it montages through it
then the movie ends and it's done this
movies about two hours 15 minutes long
you feel like it was film to be three
hours long and they just cut it back so
like add two hours 15 minutes just
that's fine that's good enough all right
I guess so it just feels like the last
part of the movie the last act of the
movie was just montage through that is a
bummer just doesn't change the fact that
hacksaw Ridge
because that great performance is it has
great heart you could tell people in the
theater at a point we're pride crying
you know it's like people being proud
and they're crying for someone because
they're proud this sounds like infra
nose out through nose that's what it
sounds like that's pride crying it's one
of the uplifting stories of 2016 that
I've seen personally and I will say
Hacksaw ridge is awesome tacular is safe
to say that that dude's going for his
big boss title like his achievement but
you don't know generally speaking in
Metal Gear Solid games you beat the game
in under three hours you don't kill
anybody you get the title big boss under
three hours doesn't kill anybody
big boss just saying right guys so
hacksaw Ridge have you seen it what did
you think about it what's your favorite
war movie of all time whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]